(whooshing)
(thudding)
(dramatic music)
Even when I was playing
football, I'd kick the ball
against the wall and I'd
pretend that I scored a goal
and I'd run off and I'd be raising my hand
and visualizing a arena full of fans.
That was something I'd done as a kid
out on my own, I just run around kicking
the ball.
And then I suppose when
I came to these events
and started training MMA
and I came to an event,
it was like okay.
And then,
now I'm doing it.
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever have, let's call it
a normal job, kind of a 9-to-5?
- Yeah, 'cause the Irish thing
is to get into a trade
straightaway, I was no different.
As soon as I finished school
Doing this, doing that.
They didn't know what
it was, they didn't know
what MMA was,
As far as they were concerned,
my mom and dad, I'm talking
about, as far as they
were concerned, I was just
getting into a cage and fighting
with some other guy, they
didn't know nothing about it.
No one did, really,
but
You know what I mean, I knew (mumbles).
Because obviously I had a lot
of fights with me dad, a lot--
- [Interviewer] What trade did you get?
- Were you actually in the trenches?
- I mean it was an industrial
so I'd be like building this.
It'd be like the plumbing that
would be needed in a place
like this, six o'clock in the morning
and the motorway.
To get to the motorway and
then I'd stand on the edge
of the motorway and wait
for a bloke to drive by
so he'd give me a lift and
then the motorway was getting
renovation at times, it
would take me two hours,
2 1/2 hours to get to
the place, it was out
in the country.
And I was the first
year, so I was the worst
of the worst.
- Wow.
Then two hours to get back in
the traffic again, which is
a horrible, horrible time.
I lasted 18 months doing it, it was tough.
And then John said
'cause I was training with John
as well at the time and then
John (mumbles) and says, "I
have a show, I'm doing a show.
"I'd like you to fight in it."
My dad used to come in and
punch the hell out of me and try
and drag me out of bed.
I hadn't (mumbles)
for a few good years when
I'm (mumbles) and that was it.
It was a lot of stressful
years, know what I mean?
A lot of tough times but
Everything I do in my
life is related to this.
And that is why, now what I mean,
to be--
- Is that--
- I don't know.
I'm in phenomenal shape,
in body and mind, to me, what's unhealthy
is living an unhealthy life,
to me, what's unhealthy
is getting up and going
through the same day
every day of your life,
9-to-5 in an office
or in a,
I don't work.
That's why it's become a career
for me because I love it.
(ambient electronic music)